françois chaumont si général de brigade
et expert en géostratégie
bonsoir françois chaumont si merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
ce soir le chef du pentagone marque
espère annonce ce retrait comme
nécessaires et stratégique pour contrer
la russie donald trump lui le contredit
quelques minutes après il dit qu'il est
prêt à revenir sur cette décision si
l'allemagne était prête à contribuer
davantage à l'otan d'un point de vue
financier
au final qui croire bonsoir d'abord je
trouve quand même que le président
antoine n'est pas très sérieux si je
peux me permettre
quand on déploie douze mille soldats
dans d'autres pays de l'otan
comme cela est annoncé depuis plusieurs
mois quand même ça fait un peu curieux
ensuite la cible est très claire trump
souhaiterait que l'allemagne contribuent
puces à la défense très bien pour
l'instant constatons quand même que au
niveau européen l'allemagne par exemple
par rapport à la france donne au moins
autant sinon légèrement plus rentable de
budget de la défense
donc c'est un peu curieux et enfin on
voit bien que quel est l'objectif de
trump dans cette campagne pré électorale
c'est sans doute de d'obtenir de
nouveaux marchés d'armement pour
finalement plus mettre l'europe sous la
dépendance américaine en termes
d'armement puisque déjà nous en achetons
beaucoup mais peut-être pas suffisamment
pour trump donc je crois que monsieur
trump se trompent énormément dans ses
déclarations même s'il avait annoncé
depuis très longtemps
qui est derrière déploré ces forces mais
constatons bien que c'est une attaque
contre l'allemagne
et je ne sais pas comment l'allemagne va
réagir à cette attaque directe justement
c'était la question que j'allais vous
poser je voulais vous demander si ce
redéploiement était un bras de fer entre
washington et berlin et donc si oui vous
venez de dire oui au final quelles
conséquences diplomatiques
très honnêtement j'avoue que je suis un
petit peu dubitatif sur un résultat
quelconque d'abord la question qu'on
pourrait se poser est ce que dans six
mois donald trump sera toujours
président c'est une question très
importante qui fait partie quand même de
cette réflexion sur la défense de
l'europe
s'il n'est plus près
10dans bas ce qui a été décidé
aujourd'hui ou annoncée n'aura pas lieu
parce que ça ne se fait pas du jour au
lendemain si c'est lui qui est aux
affaires
on verra bien comment réagiront les
européens et notamment angela merkel
très honnêtement je ne vois pas comment
elle peut réagir aujourd'hui
donald trump n'a pas fait la preuve n'a
pas apporté la preuve qu'il apportait
une sécurité supplémentaire à l'europe
quelles sont les forces américaines en
europe aujourd'hui c'est moins de
cinquante mille hommes donc en gros un
tiers de civils nous sommes dans une
prise de deux terrains sept militaires
sont là en cas de crise pour
éventuellement montrer qu'il ya une
détermination politique et non pas
militaire des états unis à protéger
l'europe avec trump ce n'est pas
possible
ensuite vous avez dit au début de votre
revenu de votre de vos questions c'est
pour répondre à la russie à la menace
russe
très honnêtement qu'elle menace russe am
face à ces situations
je n'ai pas à défendre une politique
russe une politique américaine jeudi que
cette vision très stratégique des états
unis et de trump à particulier pour moi
ne revenez pas très sensée et j'irai
même une n'a pas de sens voilà c'est un
peu ce que je dirai ce soir et quel
avenir pour le temps qui a été créé à
l'époque pour faire face au bloc
soviétique qui n'existe plus maintenant
repositionner des forces en pologne et
dans les états baltes quel objectif
alors pour la pologne c'est très clair
il s'agit et cette annonce était déjà
depuis plusieurs semaines
il ya déjà mis l'homme qui était
annoncée début juillet il s'agit d'aller
vers un pays paie lection présidentielle
en pologne on sait que le président
andré duda et est parti du côté de
washington pour rencontrer
donald trump et cette annonce a été
faite à ce moment-là tout à fait mais
faut pas se faire d'illusions quand on
parle de sécurité par les armées il ya
des deals et là il ya un deal
il est très clair que la pologne et les
états unis dans des relations
bilatérales et non pas multilatérale
c'est important et à ce titre là c'est
un coin dans l'union européenne premier
temps vous parlez de l'otan
certes mais est-ce que l'otan a
totalement besoins des états unis
aujourd'hui
glee une certaine mesure mais jusqu'à
quand or malheureusement peut-être que
les états européens ne pas totalement
conscience que la protection américaine
ne
y'aura pas si trump reste aux affaires
est ce que j'ai dit et quelques instants
lorsque j'ai dit est ce que trump sera
toujours président dans six mois je
pense qu'aujourd'hui pour répondre à une
autre question vous avez posé sur
l'allemagne
je pense qu'à une situation attentiste
on verra en janvier 2021
si effectivement le président des états
unis est toujours preuve si ce n'est pas
lui
tout ce qui vient d'être dit n'aura pas
lieu à mon avis mais cela n'engage que
moi
s'il est toujours aux affaires alors là
effectivement il y aura une négociation
et je ne sais pas quelques nouvelles
pour un avoir
mais pour répondre à la question
initiale que je vous avais posé un quel
avenir pour le temps qui a été créé à
l'époque pour faire face au bloc
soviétique qui n'existe plus maintenant
alors l'otan il faut bien pour cause de
transe considération c'est vrai la
menace de l'union soviétique a disparu
néanmoins à l'otan a un avantage énorme
c'est qu'ils obligent les états
européens à faire un effort sur leur
défense et à standardiser leurs
procédures à travailler ensemble car
aucun état européen aujourd'hui
consacrera autant d'argent à la défense
que d'autres états donc c'est une
mutualisation du moins des moyens
militaires dont on apprend à travailler
ensemble à agir ensemble avant une
politique de sécurité commune donc
l'otan sert à cela maintenant la place
des états unis est importante elle
contribue à environ je crois 25 % du
budget de fonctionnement
par contre tous ses moyens militaires
représente beaucoup plus il est certain
que ce que fait 30 aujourd'hui un peu
apporté finalement un soutien ce que
veut faire le président macron c'est à
dire une défense plus européenne
même au sein de l'otan car il n'a jamais
été question ni pour les français ni
pour les états de l'union européenne ou
de l'europe de ne plus être dans l'otan
l'otan restera en revanche il s'agit
sans doute de reprendre un peu plus les
responsabilités et peut-être face à un
ali était très peu fiable
bah finalement le pousse un petit peu
dehors gentiment mais à condition qu'on
mette les moyens pour le faire
citroën veut qu effectivement
l'allemagne paye mais si l'allemagne
paye la diminution du budget américain
sera moins influente et peut-être que la
défense européenne sera plus importante
et plus forte
merci françois souvent c'est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes général de brigade et expert
en géostratégie